except that Patrick O'Flynn was talking
about you when he talked about poisonous
wrong hands no doubt no doubt I mean you
know Patrick O'Flynn has chosen to
ignore this across the whole of the
campaign period never once raised it
with me never once raised it with anyone
around me and has now chosen after the
election to make somewhat of a public
rao about this situation seems to me
that an elected MEP should not go
behaving like that let's be clear about
this you are leaving you Kip have you
been fired have you resigned what's
happened well my contract was always due
to expire at the end of this month I was
only general election staff I was there
to help Nigel along the way to help him
with speeches briefings debate prep so
on and so forth and my contract absolves
you to expiry in a month I chose a
couple of days ago to take holiday until
the end of the month so any any sort of
aspersions that I've been fired or
incorrect my contract was naturally due
to end and I'm happy to say that I will
be moving back into journalism for
Breitbart London and if Patrick O'Flynn
thinks that he's seen aggressive style
tactics before he ain't seen nothing yet
so you won't be going back to work for
Nigel Farage or for you Kip no i won't i
have had several job offers this
afternoon and i decided to accept the
job offer at my previous parish of
bright part london back into journalism
where i will be scrutinizing quite
heavily what the red hue Kip team are
trying to do to the organization we've
seen over the past few weeks and the
past few hours specifically a very very
unprofessional way of going about things
inside the party and I intend to shine a
light on that very very heavily are you
a party member I am a party member i was
a party member going into journalism
i'll be resigning my party membership i
don't think it's appropriate to be a
party member if you're a journalist and
you know I wish Nigel all the best
just clearly the best person to lead the
party he's clearly the best communicator
in British politics around and for
Patrick O'Flynn to call him snarling I
think shows what sort of pedigree
Patrick O'Flynn has in politics I mean
he's been elected by people I believe in
the East of England region who don't
expect him to go around behaving like
this all right there isn't the root of
this problem that Nigel Farage was very
clear he said to me he said it in his
memoirs if he was not elected as mp4
thanet south he would be resigning as
leader and learned behold within four
days he comes back as leader and people
tonight are saying they were put under
intense pressure on the National
Executive by people like you and others
to make sure that Farage kept that job
we have to have an understanding of the
party in the constitution of the party
before making comments like that the
party that the national executive of the
party doesn't answer to people like me
it doesn't even take advice from people
like me I had no dealings at all with
the National Executive Committee all
along the way the first I heard of it
was a big round of applause coming out
of the UK boardroom I walk down the
hallway and heard that the NEC had
rejected Nigel's resignation that he was
due to stay on I had absolutely no hand
in that and for people like a Patrick or
whoever else who was trying to pull the
party in a direction that it has never
been a you know created to go in I think
chose where they're coming from it in
ain't you capes best interests let's be
clear about this I mean if you want to
resign you can resign and he clearly
wanted to come back was that your advice
no I don't think he wanted to come back
i think he saw no other option for the
party that then that he could he should
come back I mean the options that were
being presented to him as I understand
it was for the party to be pulled in a
very strange direction with tax rises
and you know rhetoric around immigration
that just didn't ring true to the actual
facts about immigration into the United
Kingdom and if
Nigel saw that as well I worked 21 years
for this I'll be damned if I let it go
to part but the suggestion is that some
of the harder racist rhetoric
particularly talking about AIDS people
infected with AIDS being treated on the
National Health Service all that comes
from American influence right wingers
like you that that's not true you kit
well i mean i sat in on the meeting for
the debate prep for the debate where he
mentioned HIV migrants i didn't have
much of an influence on that meeting I
sort of SAT there and took notes as as
as an advisor does and I can tell you
that there was one person who was
salivating like a dog with his pedigree
chum being opened and that wasn't me
when Nigel mentioned the HIV line so you
know I find it quite galling the people
would try to scapegoat me for something
like that I was the one who went to the
press after Nigel said that and said
that it was a shock and awe tactic
that's not something I would buy into
that's not something I would necessarily
have advised Nigel to do but I think the
case is the facts remain about HIV
migrants into the UK you kept as a party
has had many letters in from British HIV
sufferers who say that they're having
problems getting HIV treatment because
of the number of tourists health
tourists coming into the country and
being placed above them so you know I
don't think it was necessarily a bad
thing to do having said that it wasn't
me okay I think it has been disputed by
many in the NHS those claims but let's
leave that to one side are you saying
there should be no place at the party
now for Patrick O'Flynn absolutely what
I'm saying you cannot go to a national
newspaper and air internal party
grievances as an elected representative
of the party it is wholly unprofessional
and I think Patrick should absolutely
consider his position I mean I have no
problem with him as a bloke I think he's
a nice chap he has some good ideas but
unfortunately over the past 24 hours he
has shown himself to be utterly
unprofessional and undeserving of
holding that title in holding a
spokesperson
all for the UK Independence Party I
think Patrick should take some time out
I know he has some issues that he has to
deal with I feel for him I want to say
to him you know that's that's fine you
know you go away you deal with those
things come back in due course you know
nobody's blaming anybody for making
mistakes but when mistakes are made
somebody has to step back and say right
I shouldn't have done that and I'll come
back at a later day and I think that's
what Patrick should do it could be
expelled of course from the party well
it could be but you know what I i do say
even though he sort of had these
excoriating attacks on me for the last
24 hours and do say that actually I
think his heart is generally in the
right place i'm not sure he's
necessarily a kipper throwing through
but if he believes he is then I think
the party should give him the benefit of
the doubt and I think he should just
take some time off see where his
politics lies see where his personal
life is and maybe you know maybe return
to the party in six or twelve months
this course and thank you very much need
for John